i'm sure you've seen these rumors nick
austin and you
are you guys dating i'm just kind of
focusing on my music and just trying to
do
um my thing and i also trying to keep
you know any relationships or anything
that i'm doing privately private
before we kind of get started i mean
we're living in wild times right now
how how has life been for you i guess
since
march um it's been quite the roller
coaster it's been very turbulent and
confusing but
um i've been trying to make the best of
it and keep sane and
continue to make music in such a weird
time i kind of actually was like
coincidentally on a
mental health journey like at the start
of it um
when this all hit and when it was at its
peak so i think i kind of was able
at first i thought it was a disadvantage
because i was like great right when i
finally am getting a control of my
mental health i'm like
going to be forced into isolation which
is like the number one
cause of you know depression for a lot
of people and so i was pretty
worried at first but i feel like it was
actually a blessing in disguise in a lot
of ways because i actually
was able to really focus properly and
not have
outlets like you know going to your
friends or going to parties or whatever
it might be like distracting me i was
able to really take like
literally two months by myself and like
just completely isolate and yeah know
myself i learned some french
did you really yeah that was the coolest
thing i'd
what can you say in french now it's a
few things i could say something
sweet like which means
i think you'll never understand how much
i love you i can say
which means my little pig i could say
really random stuff like
it's really random but i bust it out you
mentioned your mental health and like
being on this journey
how are you doing now like do you feel
good um yeah i think that that's like
been a big part of
this mental health journey for me um has
been realizing that i'm not always gonna
be good and like
if i say you know i am good it's okay if
tomorrow i wake up and i don't feel good
and i feel like sometimes people kind of
try to like categorize
themselves and be like well i say i'm
good so then tomorrow if i wake up and
i'm not good something must be really
wrong but it's like you know we're human
beings and we're all very
emotional creatures if you're anything
like me and so i think that
it's been important for me to recognize
that like every day is gonna be
different
and um each day comes with its own
struggle and
that's fine and it's okay to be good one
day and not good the next i think that's
important to note
yeah a thousand percent you you have
been
despite quarantine i feel like you've
been booked and you've been busy lately
you performed baby at the the ema's you
sang the national anthem at the stanley
cup in
i think september how is it to be
performing during these times and with
all these different
like safety protocols in place
yeah it's fun it's just still is weird
you know like the
um the national anthem for example was
filmed at a studio with no one around
whereas usually it would be on the rink
when
you know a arena or some of some kind
and it's just kind of a bummer that
these things obviously aren't
taking place in real life like i i think
it's great that you know we're
all adapting or trying to at least um
safely but it's
still i'm i'm someone who thrives off of
like energy and people
and their voices and
their energy so it's it's been
interesting for me
of course is is the performing though
getting you more excited about
this debut album yeah definitely i
i just want to perform it like i love
performing and i love touring and
singing and dancing and just like that's
always what i've loved first is
performing so
i hope that we end up able to do all of
that but yeah i'm so excited for my
album to come out
it's it's called life support right
why why are you calling it life support
um lifesport felt like the perfect title
when i was making it
um because it really was such a
lifeline for me and it was really like
one of the only reasons i got out of bed
in the morning was to go make
um not the only reason was to go make
this album and it was like my motivation
and i thank it
for actually like keeping me alive in a
lot of ways and i felt like i was
falling into a really dark um
heavy depression and i was able to kind
of work through it
with making this album it was very
therapeutic for me and it was
my outlet and i'm just really really
grateful for it and whilst
going to therapy i was also going to
therapy in the studio so
it was rewarding to say the least for
sure
i feel like those are hey that's amazing
and i'm happy to know that you're doing
well but also
i mean to think that like you were in
such a dark place and music in a way
sort of like pulled you out of that and
and
saved you what put you in that dark
place
to begin with um i've struggled with my
mental health the majority of my life i
have a lot of memories just always kind
of having anxiety or always feeling this
like overwhelming sense of
depression that i could never seem to
shake and um
if i did it was very momentary it wasn't
long lasting at all and i just always
kind of struggled and didn't have the
verbiage or the
um outlet or tools to
you know get me help um
and i think therapy particularly is
something that's highly stigmatized and
something that people kind of
there still is this like shame and guilt
around it i don't i don't think that
somebody would say
um you know i'm going to get my nails
done as as freely as they would
hopefully say i'm going to get therapy i
think that that's something that's
very stigmatized and it's unfortunate
because therapy really helped me
tremendously
and i encourage anyone who feels like
they need someone to talk to to
try to find a therapist who can help you
and understand you but
yeah i wouldn't say anything in
particular kind of got me there i think
it was just years of built up
um trauma and events that i had kind
of overloved and i chose to ignore and
power through life pretending like
everything was fine and that that
catches up to you eventually and i was
getting triggered over things i didn't
even know
why or what like it was just very
confusing and i think it's being
somebody who really loves like
to know things and i like value
knowledge so much i was getting really
frustrated with myself that i was
official for me and now i'm able to set
boundaries and i'm able to be
a healthier person for myself and the
people around me who love me
know about you know a lot of stuff that
i've dealt with throughout my life and
you have to have people who protect you
and i i couldn't do it alone and i'm
very grateful to the people who
guard me and help me out um well i love
that you
are trying to destigmatize therapy
because i
am all for therapy i think it's super
important do you
feel like this album from a a
songwriting
perspective is kind of about that
journey or like what do you feel is the
real
um inspiration behind it yeah it was a
breakup album to be completely frank
with you and then i was like
i'm not reducing myself to my like
breakup this is i have so much more to
talk about
and so i kind of was like halfway
through the album i was like can we stop
talking about him and like we did it and
we got it and now let's talk about like
what i've dealt with throughout the
breakup and whatever so
it definitely had surrounded my breakup
was like the biggest i think the pivotal
conversation piece during writing it but
like
yeah i just got to the point that i was
like i am not reducing myself to this
and yeah i'm not calling it a breakup
album and i'm not gonna allow anybody to
like make it like that's what it is
because it's not and my breakup was a
part of it
but i want just one chapter um i also
want to know
there's you know my song selfish like
there there are times that i still get
sad over somebody who i might have loved
and dated and i think that that's
also something that i want to make sure
that people who are
receiving and consuming my music um
don't get misconstrued because i
i made sure my album showed the variety
and the juxtaposition of a breakup and
how it actually goes which is
you know the pendulum swings one way and
then it swings the other and one morning
i can wake up feeling
like a baddie and like i don't have to
you know never speak to him ever again
and who cares and the next day i could
be
sobbing hysterically reading through a
scrapbook you know what i mean and i
just wanted to make sure that that was
something i showcased
because i was consuming a lot of music
that was very either like be sad
or go be a bad [ __ ] there's no in
between and i was like
there is an in between and it's human
for you to feel one day
one day one way and one day the next and
i'm just like that's what i really
wanted to do so yeah i'm definitely
past it but it's still a part of me and
i i am someone who takes relationships
very seriously it's a
gift and a curse and so um i'll always
you know care for this person but i
think that i'm
really grateful i've been able to
channel um
a hard time into something hopefully i
can help other people
do we know who this person is you don't
want to say his name
um it's it's honestly not even about
anyone in particular like i
have been through a few breakups at this
point like two kind of big serious ones
but
um it wasn't really about either boy in
particular it was really just about my
experience and what
i went through um from 15 to i'm
almost 22 from 15 to 21 i've pretty much
been in relationships the entire time
and
i don't know just really more about an
experience and i have nothing to love
for
both of my exes what is the biggest
thing that you hope we learn about you
because i do feel like you've been
in this industry for a while i feel like
we've watched you on red carpet since
you were like 15
maybe even younger so like what do you
hope we learn
um just that i'm human and that
we're all just human beings who are
going through this very strange
thing called life and i think that um i
wanted to just show an honest side to
myself and i
feel like i've been kind of someone
who's been
misunderstood by the people who have
gotten to know me over the past years
and i hope that people who don't know me
yet i get to introduce myself on the
right foot and that's all i can hope for
and i'm
really excited to get it out into the
world for sure is it still gonna come
out this year or do you think 2021 now
well i mean for everything that happened
unfortunately we had to push it into
2021
but um early 2021.
i could break my heart saying it because
i wish it was this year but
um you know it was a very unpredictable
year and obviously we had to adapt so
yeah early 2021. i understand that
um you've said in the past i was
watching just like old interviews
today that you did um and you said there
was a moment where
everything was taken away but like
through
those times you feel like you became a
better
artist and i'm just wondering how so
yeah i mean i was kind of picked up and
dropped by everyone who
had first started working with me when i
was 12 and just had started and
um kind of felt uh
i don't want to say abandoned because
it's i don't blame anyone but that's how
it felt as a child
to you know have have a whole team of
people kind of like
give up on you this is how i perceived
it it was really tough and i had to
overcome it and i had to kind of be like
you know what i
i believe in myself and even if all
these people don't i still do at the end
of the day
and it was kind of this like
self-fulfilling prophecy of like you
know maybe
maybe this had to happen in order for me
to gain my self-confidence and i was
like you know what i have to do this and
i'm gonna
continue to do this whether it's on my
own or it's supported by
you know some of the biggest people in
the world and i'm happy that i did
because i feel like i'm
really proud of where i've gotten myself
and um
are you are you still close with those
people i think you're talking about
scooter
and justin um i speak to jefferson yeah
i just spoke to justin recently he's
doing amazing
um i adore him and haley and
yeah i i'm yeah definitely so close to
them okay well that's good to hear
so not all was for nothing no there's no
issues that's always the thing too
is like there's no bad blood anywhere
there's no problems this is just how i
as a child perceive the whole situation
um
and so no we're all completely good i
speak to all of them still and
there's no issues anywhere and i'm
nothing but abundantly grateful for the
recognition they all provided me when i
was so so young
um it was just hard to go through no
matter what so
yeah that's it you came out the other
side i'm sure you've seen these rumors
uh nick austin and you
are you guys dating are you trying to be
single for a little bit are you focusing
on
yourself or are you um yeah i'm just
kind of focusing on my music
and just trying to do um my thing
and i also am trying to keep you know
any relationships or anything that i'm
doing privately private i'm definitely
someone who believes in having
a private life amidst all this
and if there's something that i want
publicize
i can choose whether to have that out
there or not
i will say there were rumors you don't
have to answer this one either
but you and david dobrik did you see all
these rumors
david's one of my best friends okay i've
actually been secretly married for like
four years
no one knows that would actually be kind
of epic
yeah but i guess i just pulled the beans
stuff before i let you go
i mean you have this album coming out i
believe you launched a makeup
collection back in september what's kind
of
what does the future of the madison beer
empire look like
um i don't know honestly i'm just trying
to get this album out that's all i could
really focus on right now and
um just keep making music keep inspiring
hopefully
keep destigmatizing mental health um
just things that i'm passionate about
hopefully that's what i'll continue to
do
[Music]